other collaborations
we talked about you being the hook guys
you said yeah i could see that
which means that you're definitely going
to be on some [ __ ] that's already been
recorded coming out
but like what are you already having it
tucked like hook wise i know
you're going to very shortly people
aren't going to be able to afford the
feature but
you know right now um i just did some
[ __ ] with tyga
um and i also did some [ __ ] arrests
recently
tiger and russ yeah well separately but
yeah yeah i don't want to hear a tiger
in wrestling
i'd like to hear i'm just being honest i
don't want to hear them
together on the song i'd like to hear
you want a song with tigers right right
away i wouldn't want to hear tyga on a
song with tiger though
i'd like like you'd have to be on it for
me to like shout out to saga though last
kings you know what i'm saying
um how did you tyga i mean no tiger's a
legend let's not get it [ __ ] up
but how did you and tyga get get
together you just reached out tapped in
nah he tapped in on instagram
off the strength he was just like let's
work and i was like damn that's crazy
a lot of people be tapping in e40
reached out
you got you know what you always got to
give 40 the feature man that's going to
come from
that's automatic e40 come on you ever
see
like look at the track list on e40s
albums and you'll see all the features
and you'll be like
nobody has ever told the 40 no for the
future because he'd be having
everybody on his [ __ ] no matter how big
it's like yo no he's got it e40s album
[ __ ] tracklist
first of all they're like 80 songs it
full drop a triple disc on you bro
nah but one thing about e40 he one of
the artists
it's a few of them that never have a
weak verse oh never
mizzy another one of them oh forever
yo that's crazy mazzy has never had a
weak verse ever and e40 is one of the
greatest of all time
i think he's on the west coast uh when
you do the round mount rushmore
he's the only bay representative up
there um
shout out to 40 man 40 water is a legend
damn so e40 is tapped in russ so you and
russ have actually done a
like the record exists for you or for
him
uh both so you guys you guys do too yeah
a little trade-off
something like that okay is that gonna
be the one that you tucked like okay
this is an album one um
i'm having debates with peru right now
i'm trying to put it on the deluxe for
no level
oh hey honestly it might be a moment
right man honestly
especially because he just tweeted about
you right now are you trying to put it
on the album or the
or the deluxe of the ep i want to put it
on the deluxe
once i once i got something i'm ready to
go hey i'm voting for that because i
like to hear it
yeah but your boy probably
talks it's still in talks